Parents today are documenting their children's lives in ways no previous generation could. From ultrasound images to funny toddler videos to graduation photos, kids' milestones and everyday moments often end up online. In fact, parents posting about their children is so common, there's even a word for it. Sharenting. For many parents, sharenting is a way to connect with far-flung friends and family, seek advice and support, or just document family life. But psychologists and other researchers are increasingly asking what it means for kids. What are the effects of growing up with a digital footprint that begins before birth? How do young children and teens feel about it?
如今的父母记录孩子生活的方式是前所未有的。从超声波图像到有趣的幼儿视频，再到毕业照，孩子的成长里程碑和日常点滴往往最终都会出现在网上。事实上，父母在网上发布关于孩子的内容非常普遍，甚至为此产生了一个专门的词汇：Sharenting（晒娃）。对许多父母来说，晒娃是与远方的亲友保持联系、寻求建议和支持，或者仅仅是记录家庭生活的一种方式。但心理学家和其他研究人员越来越关注这对孩子意味着什么。带着从出生前就开始的数字足迹长大，会有什么影响？幼儿和青少年对此有何感受？
How can families balance connection and community with kids need for privacy? And how is AI changing the risks of sharenting in 2026? Welcome to Speaking of Psychology, the flagship podcast of the American Psychological Association that examines the links between psychological science and everyday life. I'm Kim Mills. My guest today is Dr. Kenesha Sinclair McBride, a licensed clinical psychologist and the associate chief of integrated behavioral health at Boston Children's Hospital. She's also an assistant professor of psychology at Harvard Medical School. As a clinician, she provides evidence-based treatment for children and adolescents
家庭如何在保持联系和社区互动的同时，满足孩子对隐私的需求？2026年，人工智能又如何改变了晒娃的风险？欢迎收听《心理学谈话》，这是美国心理学会的旗舰播客，旨在探讨心理科学与日常生活之间的联系。我是主持人金·米尔斯。今天的嘉宾是肯尼莎·辛克莱·麦克布莱德博士，她是波士顿儿童医院的执业临床心理学家，也是综合行为健康副主任。她还是哈佛医学院的心理学助理教授。作为一名临床医生，她为患有抑郁症、焦虑症和其他疾病的儿童和青少年提供循证治疗。
with depression, anxiety, and other conditions. She also writes and speaks on adolescent mental health, social media and digital well-being. She recently spoke with APA's magazine Monitor on Psychology for an article on Sherenting and its implications for children and families. Dr. Sinclair McBride, thank you for joining me today. Thank you so much for having me. Let's start with a basic question. What is Sherenting?
她还撰写并发表关于青少年心理健康、社交媒体和数字福祉的文章和演讲。最近，她接受了美国心理学会《心理学监测》杂志的采访，讨论了晒娃及其对儿童和家庭的影响。辛克莱·麦克布莱德博士，感谢您今天参加我们的节目。非常感谢您的邀请。让我们从一个基本问题开始。什么是晒娃？
How do you define it in your work and when you're talking to parents and kids? So sharing is sort of a modern word that we've come up to kind of describe what it means to share your parenting online. And when we think about that, it can take so many different forms. Most people think about sharing on social media. But before that, there were blogs, people posted on Twitter, things like that. So this is not like a new phenomenon, but it's definitely taking off in a different way in 2026. What motivates most parents to share their children's lives online?
在您的工作中，以及与家长和孩子交谈时，您是如何定义它的？“晒娃”是一个现代词汇，用来描述在网上分享育儿点滴的行为。当我们思考这个问题时，它有多种表现形式。大多数人想到的是在社交媒体上分享。但在那之前，还有博客、推特等平台。所以这并不是一个新现象，但在2026年，它确实以一种不同的方式兴起。是什么促使大多数父母在网上分享孩子的生活？
And before we get into the risks, are there benefits? So most people are kind of going into this as a bid for connection and to maintain relationships and keep family up to date, friends up to date, people that they don't get to see on a regular basis. A lot of people talk about, you know, posting things on Facebook for the grandparents, that sort of thing. And for other people,
在探讨风险之前，它有好处吗？大多数人这样做是为了建立联系，维持人际关系，让家人和朋友了解近况，特别是那些无法经常见面的人。很多人谈到在Facebook上为祖父母发布照片之类的东西。对于其他人来说，
there are kind of parenting communities that can kind of spring up based off of various different parenting philosophies, parenting styles, different identities people can hold. So there can be kind of positive community building aspects of this, and most people are going into it with that intention. So one of the biggest concerns
基于各种不同的育儿理念、育儿风格和人们持有的不同身份，会涌现出各种育儿社区。因此，这可能具有积极的社区建设方面，大多数人也是抱着这种初衷去做的。所以，人们对晒娃提出的最大担忧之一
that people raise about charanting is digital privacy. What kinds of privacy risks are parents creating when they post about their children online and with the rise of AI? Are those risks different now than they were even a few years ago? I would say that the risk definitely increased now because, you know, from the beginning, when you post something on the internet, it no longer really belongs to you. Anyone can download it. Anyone can access it and do whatever they would like with it. So there's that component. And now that we have AI, people can manipulate images that are even very harmless, very innocent into things that are more sinister. So there are new problems. Let's talk about consent. At what age can children meaningfully weigh in on whether they want their photos or stories
是数字隐私。当父母在网上发布关于孩子的信息时，他们会造成什么样的隐私风险？随着人工智能的兴起，这些风险与几年前相比是否有所不同？我认为风险现在肯定增加了，因为从一开始，当你把东西发布到互联网上时，它就不再真正属于你了。任何人都可以下载它，任何人都可以访问它，并用它做任何他们想做的事情。这就是其中的一部分。现在有了人工智能，人们可以将非常无害、非常天真的图像操纵成更险恶的东西。所以出现了新的问题。让我们谈谈同意权。孩子在多大年龄可以有意义地权衡他们是否希望自己的照片或故事
shared? And is there an age at which they should have full veto power? This is such an interesting component of the issue because technically kids can't really consent in terms of legally having the right to control over the decisions their parents are making. But I often think about it as a kind of we need to get their assent, similar to when we consent families for research studies. We need kids need to understand what it means to be posted online, what are the parameters and should be able to have the right to say no. Developmentally, a very young child doesn't understand what that means. But as kids get older and have more of a sense of identity and a sense of awareness, they really do. And I do think that at that point, and that could be different for every family, it's very important to listen to your child.
被分享？是否有一个年龄段，他们应该拥有完全的否决权？这是这个问题中非常有趣的一部分，因为从技术上讲，孩子们在法律上并没有权利控制父母所做的决定，所以他们无法真正“同意”。但我经常认为这是一种我们需要获得他们“赞同”的方式，类似于我们在研究中征求家庭同意的过程。我们需要让孩子们理解在网上发布意味着什么，参数是什么，并且他们应该有权说“不”。从发育角度来看，非常年幼的孩子并不理解这意味着什么。但随着孩子长大，有了更多的自我意识和认知，他们确实理解了。我认为到了那个阶段——每个家庭的情况可能不同——倾听孩子的意见非常重要。
If they're saying they don't want to be posted or they don't want that to be online, we need to listen to them. How do you start conversations about this with your kids? What questions should you be asking them? And what's a good age for starting the dialogue? You could start this really early when we're teaching about kind of body autonomy and consent, right? When we take a picture of someone, we should ask them if we're going to take a picture of you. like, I'm going to take a picture. And, you know, even a toddler can tell you yes or no that they don't want to take a picture right then, right? They'll let you know. And then from there, you know, I'm asking permission to take a picture. You could also explain what you're doing as they get older, right? So, you know, I'm taking this picture because grandma wants to see your graduation. Or, you know, I'm taking this picture to show our friends that you can swim really well now. Things like that explaining what the purpose of it is for. And as kids get older, they start knowing. about social media, right? And they're not really allowed to have their own accounts,
如果他们说不想被发布，或者不想让这些内容出现在网上，我们需要倾听他们的意见。您如何与孩子开启关于这个话题的对话？您应该问他们什么问题？开启对话的最佳年龄是什么时候？你可以在孩子很小的时候就开始，当我们教导关于身体自主权和同意权的时候，对吧？当我们给某人拍照时，我们应该问他们是否可以拍。比如，“我要拍张照了”。即使是蹒跚学步的孩子也能告诉你“是”或“不”，他们不想在那时拍照，对吧？他们会让你知道的。从那以后，我会请求许可来拍照。随着他们长大，你也可以解释你在做什么，对吧？比如，“我拍这张照片是因为奶奶想看你的毕业典礼”，或者“我拍这张照片是为了向朋友展示你现在游泳游得很好”。诸如此类，解释拍照的目的。随着孩子长大，他们开始了解社交媒体，对吧？他们并不真正被允许拥有自己的账户，
hopefully, for a certain age. But that doesn't mean that that's the beginning of that child's digital footprint. A lot of people are already, as you said, from ultrasound on, are already posted on the internet. So talking to kids about that and listening when they're like, I don't want you to post that or I don't want to be on your page anymore. I think that's important. But it can start really early. When do they really seem to understand what the question is about? I mean, if it's about putting a picture on social media, do they get what that means and where the picture will go, not just to grandma? So I think around like late elementary school age, when we start thinking about metacognition and being able to perspective take and think about other people's thinking, they start understanding that this is going somewhere, right? But the permanency of that, I would say even sometimes adolescents don't get that, right?
希望在一定年龄之前是这样。但这并不意味着那是孩子数字足迹的开始。正如你所说，很多人从超声波开始就已经被发布到互联网上了。所以和孩子们谈论这一点，并在他们说“我不希望你发布那个”或“我不想再出现在你的页面上”时倾听他们的意见，我认为这很重要。但这可以从很小的时候就开始。他们什么时候才能真正理解这个问题？我的意思是，如果是在社交媒体上放一张照片，他们明白这意味着什么，以及照片会去向何处，而不仅仅是给奶奶看吗？我认为在小学高年级左右，当我们开始思考元认知、能够换位思考并考虑他人的想法时，他们就开始明白这些东西会传播到别处，对吧？但对于这种永久性，我想说即使是青少年有时也不明白，对吧？
Like if I post something, it's forever and anyone can do whatever they want with it, I feel like there are adults that don't really understand. that. So we get into this very delicate situation of, right, like, what does it actually mean? And to be honest, a lot of us don't really know because we don't know in terms of like what, who has access to our data, what it means to post on some of these platforms. It's a nuanced question. What are some more of the downsides of sharenting? Have you encountered situations where negative things have happened as a result of parents sharing information and photos about their children? Clinically, I haven't necessarily seen that. I've more seeing the conversations about, you know, I don't want my parents to post this. I do want them to post that. And I can say that as adolescents are trying to develop their own sense of autonomy,
比如，如果我发布了什么东西，它就是永久的，任何人都可以用它做任何他们想做的事，我觉得有些成年人也不太理解这一点。所以我们陷入了一种非常微妙的境地，即这到底意味着什么？老实说，我们很多人并不真正知道，因为我们不知道谁能访问我们的数据，也不知道在这些平台上发布意味着什么。这是一个微妙的问题。晒娃还有哪些弊端？您是否遇到过因父母分享孩子的信息和照片而导致负面后果的情况？在临床上，我并没有特别看到这种情况。我更多看到的是关于“我不希望父母发布这个，我希望他们发布那个”的对话。我可以肯定地说，当青少年试图发展自己的自主感时，
right, having some control over your image is super important. And you could see how there would be negative downsides to not feeling like you had control. Often what ends up happening clinically is kids wanting to post too much or tell too much about themselves and parents being concerned, right? There are all these different layers to it. And a lot of it depends on what kind of social media platforms, families are using. You know, there's a lot of, like, parents posting on things like Facebook for older relatives, but the kids aren't using that stuff. So some of them don't even really care what's happening over there, but they might have
对自己的形象拥有一定的控制权是非常重要的。你可以看出，如果感觉自己没有控制权，会有负面的弊端。在临床上经常发生的情况是，孩子们想发布太多内容或透露太多关于自己的信息，而父母感到担忧，对吧？这其中有许多不同的层面。很大程度上取决于家庭使用什么样的社交媒体平台。你知道，有很多父母在Facebook上为年长的亲戚发布内容，但孩子们并不使用这些东西。所以他们中的一些人甚至根本不在乎那里发生了什么，但他们可能有
a real Instagram account and a fake Instagram account, or they might only use Snapchat and, like, parents don't even know what they're posting. So there's kind of a disconnect generationally between who's doing what and who's sharing what, because there's the sharing the sharenting component, and then there's the kids sharing their version of their lives. And I think there needs to be a little bit more of a conversation around what we're all doing and what the implications of that is. So what are the questions that parents should ask themselves, if not their kids, before they post about their offspring? Why am I posting this? Like, what is the
一个真实的Instagram账户和一个虚假的Instagram账户，或者他们可能只使用Snapchat，而父母甚至不知道他们在发布什么。所以在代际之间，关于谁在做什么、谁在分享什么，存在一种脱节。因为有“晒娃”的成分，还有孩子们分享他们自己生活版本的部分。我认为我们需要围绕我们都在做什么以及这带来的影响进行更多的对话。那么，父母在发布关于子女的内容之前，如果不是问孩子，应该问自己什么问题呢？“我为什么要发布这个？”比如，它的
purpose? Right. A lot of times people get so into the habit of using their phones for everything that you might not even really have a reason. You might just be posting it because that's what you do, right? And it might be good enough just to take that picture and keep it in your photo album or text it to your family, whatever you want to do. Like, it doesn't necessarily have to go on social media. So that's the first thing. The second thing, and honestly, this is kind of the overarching kind of point I was making about the kids as well, your privacy settings. What does your account look like? There are people who do the sharing thing as their business, their social media business, the influencers, for example, they don't have private accounts. And that's a whole other legal issue and a whole other kind of
目的是什么？对吧。很多时候，人们习惯了用手机做所有事情，以至于你可能根本没有理由。你可能只是因为“这就是你所做的”而发布它，对吧？也许拍下那张照片并保存在相册里，或者发短信给家人，无论你想怎么做，这就足够了。它不一定非要发到社交媒体上。所以这是第一件事。第二件事，老实说，这也是我刚才提到的关于孩子们的总体观点，即你的隐私设置。你的账户看起来是什么样的？有些人把晒娃当作他们的生意，比如网红，他们没有私人账户。这是一个完全不同的法律问题和完全不同的
parenting and ethical issue. But for the average family who's not trying to, you know, make an income off social media, do you need to have a public account? And the answer is probably no. And then, you know, doing some regular assessment of who you have following you. And like, do you need all these people to be able to see all these pictures of your family? Just a little bit more of that self-interrogation about the why and the who. Talk about, you know, is there income from this? I mean, there are some parents who are, I mean, actually exploiting their children to make money. I mean, what do you see in that arena? I mean, what are parents doing that they shouldn't be doing?
育儿和伦理问题。但对于那些不想靠社交媒体赚钱的普通家庭来说，你需要拥有一个公开账户吗？答案很可能是不需要。然后，定期评估一下谁在关注你。你需要所有这些人都能看到你家人的所有照片吗？只需要多一点关于“为什么”和“给谁看”的自我审视。谈谈是否有收入来源？我的意思是，有些父母实际上是在利用他们的孩子赚钱。您在这一领域看到了什么？父母在做什么他们不应该做的事情？
It's not just putting up a picture because Bobby can swim now. You know, I feel like we're getting to a phase that there's going to be a reckoning about this in terms of there are kids who grew up with their parents using this as their source of income, right? And there are lots of interesting accounts from young people about what that experience is like. And there are also families that have stopped posting once their kids got to a certain age when they realize that their kids are basically not assenting to this anymore. But there are people who make huge salaries from posting every moment of their children's lives. And then that is really interesting too because that's what we as consumers are viewing as content.
这不仅仅是因为“鲍比现在会游泳了”而发一张照片。我觉得我们正进入一个阶段，关于这个问题将会有一次清算，因为有些孩子是在父母利用他们作为收入来源的环境下长大的，对吧？年轻人有很多关于这种经历的有趣叙述。也有一些家庭在孩子长到一定年龄后停止了发布，因为他们意识到孩子基本上不再赞同这一点了。但有些人通过发布孩子生活的每一个瞬间赚取巨额薪水。这确实非常有趣，因为这就是我们作为消费者所看到的“内容”。
And that's the version of parenting that people are seeing or trying to emulate, right? Or they might be on their own page trying to emulate this sort of influencer, sort of lifestyle that they're seeing from the people that they're following. And so we've created this whole sort of performance-based culture where there are people making money for performing and then there are people copying that in their own lives. And is anyone actually just living and enjoying their kids? Well, I mean, that was another question I had for you, which is whether documenting family life changes the experience itself. So instead of being fully present in your children's lives, you're thinking of moments as content. Right. I think that it's hard for humans to not start viewing things like that when they're recording everything, right?
这就是人们所看到或试图效仿的育儿版本，对吧？或者他们可能在自己的页面上试图效仿他们所关注的人的那种网红生活方式。因此，我们创造了整个这种基于表演的文化，有人通过表演赚钱，然后有人在自己的生活中复制这种行为。真的有人只是在生活和享受他们的孩子吗？嗯，这是我问你的另一个问题，即记录家庭生活是否改变了体验本身。所以，你不是完全沉浸在孩子的生活中，而是把这些时刻当作“内容”来思考。对。我认为人类很难不开始那样看待事物，当他们记录一切的时候，对吧？
And it's really interesting the experience of going to your child's event or interacting with your kid without your phone versus with having the phone, right? Because you have to be fully present. It's like we talk about mindfulness so much in clinical practice. And you are much more mindful when you don't have a phone. I'm sure lots of folks have had the experience of being at an event for their kids and they look around and there are people watching it through their phone as a point. as opposed to actually like looking at the thing that's happening, right? Right, right. That's a different experience.
去参加孩子的活动或在没有手机的情况下与孩子互动，与带着手机的体验是非常不同的，对吧？因为你必须完全在场。就像我们在临床实践中经常谈论正念一样。当你没有手机时，你会更加专注。我相信很多人都有过这样的经历：在参加孩子的活动时，环顾四周，发现人们通过手机屏幕在观看，而不是真正地看着正在发生的事情，对吧？对，对。那是一种不同的体验。
And then there's this element of like, is it performance or is the kid just getting to live their lives? If you're asking them to stop what they're doing so you can take a picture of that or repeat what they're saying so you can record it. That's not, you know, letting them live in the moment. We're going to take a short break. When we return, I'll talk with Dr. Sinclair McBride about how AI is changing the risk calculus around sharenting and about how to now. navigate conversations with family and friends about how much to share online. How is AI changing sharing sharenting? There's so many different ways to think about this.
然后还有一种元素，比如，这是表演，还是孩子只是在过他们的生活？如果你要求他们停下正在做的事情以便你拍照，或者重复他们说的话以便你录音，那不是让他们活在当下。我们将进行短暂的休息。回来后，我将与辛克莱·麦克布莱德博士讨论人工智能如何改变晒娃的风险计算，以及如何与家人和朋友沟通在线分享的尺度。人工智能如何改变晒娃？思考这个问题有很多不同的方式。
There's a much more sinister component that I mentioned, that people can make all kinds of images based off of what they find. And people who don't have your family's best interests at heart or children's best interests at heart can take pictures that are innocent and turn them into something that's much more sinister. But there's also the fact that people can like just create all these different things out of the images of their kids. And so what does that mean for a child? Like, it might be fun if your parent can turn you into a dinosaur. But like, if they can like change what
正如我提到的，有一个更险恶的组成部分，人们可以根据他们发现的内容制作各种图像。那些对你的家庭或孩子没有善意的人可以拿走无辜的照片，把它们变成更险恶的东西。但还有一个事实是，人们可以利用孩子的图像创造出各种各样的东西。那么这对孩子意味着什么呢？如果你的父母能把你变成恐龙，这可能很有趣。但如果他们能改变
your appearance or change your outfit or change the location, what's real and what's fake, you know, that becomes kind of a confusing thing. Because again, so much of this is on the edge of reality. I have noticed that a lot of young people are better consumers about AI than their parents are. Like, they can tell when something is AI or they choose not to use it in a way. that some adults are not having those experiences. And I just using, you know, I turned all my family into cartoons versus like, did you really need to use AI for that? So there are these like kind of safety concerns.
你的外貌、服装或地点，什么是真的，什么是假的，你知道，这会变得令人困惑。因为同样，这其中很多都处于现实的边缘。我注意到很多年轻人比他们的父母更擅长消费人工智能。比如，他们能分辨出什么是人工智能，或者他们选择以某种方式不使用它，而一些成年人却没有这种体验。我只是用“我把全家人都变成了卡通人物”这种方式，而不是“你真的需要为此使用人工智能吗？”所以存在这些安全方面的担忧。
And then it's also this sort of like self-concepts concern of like, do I need to be perfected by AI for my picture to be posted on social media? I think you're right about people not getting it. I mean, I had some friends over for dinner last night. And one of them was talking about all these videos you see of. tiny kids in animal shelters where they're opening the door and letting little kids play with animals. And I'm saying, no, no, I used to volunteer in a shelter. We would never do that. But adults don't know the difference. Right. It looks really real to them. Yeah. And maybe that's harmless, but maybe it's not.
然后还有这种关于自我概念的担忧，比如“我是否需要通过人工智能来完善自己，我的照片才能发布在社交媒体上？”我想你说得对，人们确实不明白。我的意思是，昨晚我有朋友来家里吃晚饭。其中一个人在谈论你在动物收容所看到的那些小视频，小孩子们打开门让小动物玩耍。我说：“不，不，我以前在收容所做过志愿者。我们绝不会那样做。”但成年人不知道区别。对，在他们看来这看起来非常真实。是的。也许那是无害的，但也可能不是。
I mean, you know, this example feels benign, but it gives such an important context to how real this stuff looks. Like you have that information, right? Like you have the experience of volunteering at the shelter. a lot of my patients know you have to be 13 or whatever the age is to be able to. But like if you don't know that information, you might think that's something that can be done. That can get much more dangerous when we're thinking about things that are unsafe or not recommended. So does this come up in your practice? I mean, how do you talk to parents? Do you see both parents and children?
我的意思是，你知道，这个例子看起来是良性的，但它为这些东西看起来有多真实提供了重要的背景。你有这些信息，对吧？比如你有在收容所做志愿者的经验。我的很多病人知道你必须年满13岁或达到某个年龄才能这样做。但如果你不知道这些信息，你可能会认为那是可以做的事情。当我们考虑到不安全或不推荐的事情时，这可能会变得危险得多。那么这在您的实践中会出现吗？您如何与家长交谈？您是同时见家长和孩子吗？
And do you discuss this? So, yes, I often work with families. I primarily see kids and adolescents. but that family work is always a part of it. It's interesting. A lot of young people are thinking about this in a different way than their families in terms of like what does it mean for AI to be a part of our lives, what are the climate implications of it.
你们讨论这个问题吗？是的，我经常与家庭合作。我主要看儿童和青少年，但家庭工作始终是其中的一部分。这很有趣。许多年轻人正在以不同于他们家庭的方式思考这个问题，比如人工智能成为我们生活的一部分意味着什么，它的气候影响是什么。
Do I want all this information about myself on the internet? A lot of them are focused on the things that disappear. And so helping them understand that that doesn't mean that no one can have access to it, right? And then a lot of just discussion around digital literacy and misinformation. I often also talk to young people about the fact that this is all an economy. No one has designed social media just for us to have fun. Like it's a business, right? So what does it mean the more information you put online, you're helping support someone
我想要所有关于我自己的这些信息都在互联网上吗？他们中的许多人专注于那些会消失的东西。所以帮助他们理解这并不意味着没有人能访问它，对吧？然后还有很多关于数字素养和错误信息的讨论。我也经常告诉年轻人，这一切都是一种经济。没有人设计社交媒体只是为了让我们玩得开心。它是一门生意，对吧？所以你在线发布的信息越多，你就是在支持别人的生意。这意味着什么？所以这些是我经常与病人、家庭进行的对话。有趣的是，你几乎必须让孩子们意识到这一点，比如“你现在没有考虑这个问题，但你拥有的数字足迹会跟随你进入未来”。这会跟随你进入大学申请、工作申请等等。所以你对你希望它看起来是什么样子有一定的控制权。
else's business. And what does that mean? So these are conversations that I often have with patients, with families. And it's interesting that you almost, have to bring kids to this awareness of like, you don't, you're not thinking about it right now, but the digital footprint you have, that's kind of going to follow you into the future. That can follow you into college applications, job applications, those sorts of things. And so you have some control over what you want that to look like.
但你如何与父母谈论你希望它看起来是什么样子呢？有些家庭在父母和祖父母或其他亲戚之间发生分歧，因为后者想在网上发布照片。家庭应该如何处理这些对话并设定界限？我认为当你遇到那样的冲突时，提供一些信息是有帮助的，比如你对安全、隐私和孩子同意能力的担忧，并且可能向大家庭成员解释：“我们决定不发布这些东西，或者我们只在私密账户发布”，并解释你做出这些决定的原因。安全部分对于那些不知情的亲戚来说确实是一个很好的激励因素，你可以从安全的角度设定界限。这其中很多是数字素养问题。现在为人父母的许多人算是数字原住民，但这并不意味着他们的父母或祖父母也是。
But how can you talk to your parents about what you want that to look like too? Some families run into disagreements between parents and grandparents or other relatives who want to post photos online. How should families navigate these conversations and set boundaries? I think when you kind of come into a conflict like that, it's helpful to provide some of this information in terms of, you know, your concern about safety, about privacy and about the child's ability to consent and, you know, possibly explain to the extended family member, you know, we're deciding that we're not posting these things or we only post on private and explaining why you're making those decisions. The safety piece of this can really be a really good motivator for folks who are not aware and you can kind of set that boundary from a safety perspective. A lot of this is digital literacy. So many people who are parenting right now are kind of digital natives, but that doesn't mean that their parents are or their grandparents are.
所以帮助解释背景是其中的一个重要部分。您认为围绕晒娃的规范正在改变吗？我的意思是，父母是否变得更加谨慎了？他们是否比10或15年前社交媒体刚出现时更具素养了？我想是的。我认为人们的意识在不断增强，对这一切意味着什么的担忧也在增加，特别是在儿童剥削的背景下。
So helping to explain kind of where the context is like a really important piece of this. Do you think the norms around sharenting are changing? I mean, are parents becoming more cautious? Are they actually becoming more literate than they were, you know, 10 or 15 years ago when social media was new? I think so. I think that there's a lot of growing awareness. and concern about what all this means, especially in the context of child exploitation.
你甚至可以看到，当我们谈论育儿网红时，某些州正在制定法律来管理你如何使用你的孩子和你的内容，例如。所以我认为这也在渗透到普通人身上，人们变得更加谨慎，更加体贴他们所做的事情，特别是当你考虑到全国范围内我们谈论的关于儿童剥削和这类事情时。这就像是现代版的“舞台门父母”，对吧？是的，百分之百。
You even see that with like when we talked about the parenting influencers, certain states are developing laws that kind of govern how you can use your kids and your content, for example. And so I think that is trickling down to the everyday person as well, and people being a little bit more cautious and a little bit more considerate about what they're doing, especially when you think about just like nationally the things that we're talking about when it comes to child exploitation and these sorts of things as well. It's like a modern day version of the stage door parent, right? Yeah, 100%.
你希望你的孩子成为百老汇的明星，而现在你是在剥削孩子，拿走孩子可能根本没见过的钱。我的意思是，难道不应该把一部分钱留给孩子吗？想想当涉及到童星时它是如何运作的，对吧？如果他们在工作，他们就应该得到报酬。你知道，如果我们让一个孩子在咖啡店工作而不给报酬，为什么我们允许他们成为社交媒体网红，而他们的父母却完全控制那些钱呢？嗯，对于那些不想完全从社交媒体上消失的父母来说，
You wanted your kid to be a star on Broadway, and now you're exploiting the child and taking money that the kid maybe isn't seeing. I mean, shouldn't some of that money be set aside for the child? Think about how that works when it comes to child actors, right? Like, they should, if they're working, they should be compensated. You know, if we went and let a kid work at a coffee shop and not get compensated, like, why are we letting them be social media influencers and their parents have complete control over that money, you know? Well, for parents who don't want to disappear entirely from
有没有更安全的在线分享方式，既能尊重孩子的隐私？如果你的孩子足够大，进行关于他们愿意分享什么、不愿意分享什么的对话很重要。这样你们就可以把这作为你们的框架，比如“他们不介意我拍他们的篮球比赛，但他们不希望我做那个”。所以你有这个框架。我认为拥有私人账户，定期检查谁在关注你，并像修剪树篱一样修剪你的关注者列表，对吧？我还需要让所有这些人都在我的关注者名单上吗？然后继续保持对“为什么”的关注，对吧？有些事情很有趣。
social media, are there safer ways for them to share online where they're still respecting their kids' privacy? If your kids are old enough, having that conversation about what they're comfortable sharing versus not sharing is important. So then you can all kind of have that as your framework of like, they're fine if I take a picture of their basketball game, but they don't want me to do this. So you have that as a framework. I think having private accounts regularly checking who is following. following you and kind of, you know, pruning that the way you do, like the hedges or something, right? Like, do I need to have all these people still on my, on my follower count? And then just kind of continuing to be mindful about the why, right? Like, it doesn't, some things are fun. Like,
分享育儿的快乐很好，思考你分享事情背后的原因也很重要。还要确保你分享的内容能让你的孩子以积极的形象出现。我认为有时人们想要在育儿的起伏或挣扎中获得一些支持，但我会同意让每个人都知道我最困难的时刻吗？不会。所以为什么要发布那个幼儿的脾气暴躁的视频呢？是的。而且有些这种行为正在停止，我的意思是，几年前，有一股大趋势是人们恶作剧他们的孩子，然后发布这些孩子哭泣、害怕或无论他们对孩子做什么的恐怖视频。是的，其中很多都太令人难过了。我认为超级有趣的事情是，当
you know, it's nice to share the joys of parenting and thinking about what is the reasoning behind why you're sharing things. And also making sure that you're sharing things that put your kid in a positive light. I think sometimes people, you know, want some support around the ups and downs of parenting or their struggles, but would I consent to everyone knowing about my hardest moment? No. So why should that toddler's tantrum be posted, you know? Yeah. And some of that stopping, I mean, a few years ago, there was a big move of people pranking their children and then posting these horrible videos of their children crying and getting scared or whatever they do to them. Yeah, and so many of them are so sad. And I think the thing that was super interesting is like when
那刚开始时，你并没有得到那么多的强烈反对。然后最终人们开始说：“这太荒谬了。我们为什么要这样做？”有趣的是，关于我们如何看待这类事情，风向正在转变。但是的，如果你不会对成年人这样做，如果你不想被恶作剧，如果你不想在互联网上哭泣，你的孩子也不想。嗯，有什么最后的话，最后的建议吗？我的意思是，如果人们正在考虑在互联网上发布孩子的照片，他们能记住的最好的事情是什么？思考谁将有权访问它，思考你为什么要发布它，在可能的情况下征求孩子的许可，放下你的手机，有时只是活在当下，或者思考这样一个事实：我可以拍这张照片，
that first started, you didn't get that much of a backlash. And then eventually people were like, this is ridiculous. Why are we doing this? Like, it's interesting that the tide is turning in terms of how we think about stuff like that. But yeah, if you wouldn't do it to an adult, if you don't want to be pranced, if you don't want to be crying on the internet, your child doesn't either. Well, any last words, final advice? I mean, what's the best thing that people can keep in mind if they're thinking about posting a picture of their kid on the internet? Thinking about who will have access to it, thinking about why you're posting it, asking your kids permission when you can, and putting your phone down, sometimes it's just being in the moment, or thinking about the fact that I can take this picture,
但不代表我必须现在就发布它。也许如果你决定发布，可以晚点再发，但并不是所有事情都必须是“当下的”。比如“我正在为内容拍摄”，对吧？有时我们拍照是因为我们想保存一段记忆，你可以在没有社交媒体的情况下做到这一点。并向孩子们展示说：“我要发布这个。你对此没问题吗？”我认为这是一种非常重要的方式来支持赞同和自主权，并帮助孩子们理解他们可以有自己的界限，对吧？然后它也开启了所有这些关于数字素养、关于你的数字足迹的重要对话。如果你一直在和你的孩子进行这种对话，当他们拥有自己的智能手机时，这对他们来说就不会是新鲜事了，对吧？
but doesn't mean I have to post it right now. Maybe post it later if you decide to, but everything doesn't have to be this of the moment. Like I'm filming for content, right? Like sometimes we take a picture because we want to save a other memory, and you can do that without social media. And showing it to the kids saying, I'm going to post this. Are you okay with this, Marianne? I think that's a really important way to kind of support assent in autonomy and help kids understand that they can have their own boundaries, right? And then it also opens up all these important conversations around digital literacy, around your digital footprint. If you're constantly having that conversation with your kids, this is not going to be new to them when they, you know, get a smartphone of their own, right?
他们知道这是我一直和家人谈论的事情。嗯，辛克莱·麦克布莱德博士，我想感谢您的加入。我认为这对正在收听我们节目的家长来说是有用的信息。谢谢。非常感谢您的邀请。您可以在我们的网站speakingofpsychology.org或Apple、Spotify、YouTube或您获取播客的任何地方找到《心理学谈话》的往期节目。如果您喜欢所听到的内容，请关注我们并留下评论。
They know that this is something I've been talking about with my family. Well, Dr. Sinclair McBride, I want to thank you for joining me. I think this was helpful information for the parents who are listening to us. Thank you. Thank you so much for having me. You can find previous episodes of Speaking of Psychology on our website at speakingof psychology.org or on Apple, Spotify, YouTube, or wherever you get your podcasts. And if you like what you've heard, please follow us and leave a review.
如果您对未来的播客有意见或想法，可以发送电子邮件至speakingofpsychology@apa.org。《心理学谈话》由李·温纳曼制作。感谢您的收听。代表美国心理学会，我是金·米尔斯。本集目前还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子即可发表评论。
If you have comments or ideas for future podcasts, you can email us at speaking of psychology at APA.org. Speaking of Psychology is produced by Lee Wynerman. Thank you for listening. For the American Psychological Association, I'm Kim Mills. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
如果您对未来的播客有任何意见或想法，可以发送电子邮件至speaking of psychology at APA.org。Speaking of Psychology由Lee Wynerman制作。感谢您的收听。我是美国心理学会的Kim Mills。本集目前还没有评论。点击转录稿中的任何句子即可发表评论。